the man accused of killing a bicyclist
in a dui crash late friday night
appeared in court this morning 26 year
old raymond perez hernandez is charged
in this case now this crash happened
near las vegas boulevard and pecos where
41 year old a.b mendibles was riding his
bike madison kimbrough is live there
tonight with the message from the
victims grieving family madison
known as a father brother and son take a
look at this memorial for a b as he was
killed right here last night known as an
avid bike rider a.b was on his way to
meet a friend when tragedy struck
he hit him from behind he didn't even
see him coming he didn't even get a
chance to get out of the way that phone
call is just the worst ever to get a
family grieving over the loss of one of
their own 41-year-old a.b mendiples was
killed by a drunk driver friday night
while riding his bike near pecos and las
vegas boulevard metro police confirming
that a 2007 chevy cobalt was going north
on las vegas boulevard when the driver
26-year-old raymond perez-hernandez
drove onto the sidewalk hitting and
killing a.b his family distraught saying
this type of tragedy happens too often
across the valley i'm tired of hearing
on the news every day it's somebody
people are so reckless
i think we need stricter laws
finding out this guy's charges it's not
vehicular manslaughter or anything like
that it's like you took an innocent life
i just want justice for my son i want
him to play for
what he did because they told me i can't
even see him because of his face the
driver perez hernandez was taken to the
hospital with minor injuries and is now
in custody booked into the clark county
detention center for dui related charges
abey's family wanting stricter laws on
the roadways i just wish like there was
more we can do about the drunk driving
and all that as a community we need to
come together more maybe there should be
more checkpoints this bicyclist's death
marks the 72nd deadly crash in metro's
jurisdiction this year
if you would like to help out abey's
family with funeral expenses we'll have
a link to his gofundme up on our website
on 8newsnow.com reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now